have you been surprised by the hype of
bond for because particularly for Brits
it's an event isn't it it's it's for its
it's an export we go around the world
kind of selling bond talking about
ourselves and being very proud of it
yeah yeah well it's not exactly a
surprise without wanting to be in any
way presumptuous but I still didn't
expect it and you're absolutely right
it's it's it's not only it seems to be
the biggest export of the British
economy at the moment and and I am I am
baffled a little bit you know on the
other hand it's fantastic you know that
that not not it's not a fighter plane
that is shown to the world as the
greatest achievement but actually a
story a movie with characters you know
and everything everything that sort of
attached to it from our experiencing a
story and fiction and as such it's a
cultural phenomenon and I think it's
it's a very honorable very very
honorable and fabulous sign of a healthy
and and authentic cultural life and and
what changes do you think we will see in
bonds in this film because again the
beauty of bonds is that it keeps
reinventing itself it stays ahead of the
times it feels fresh no I agree I am
because without that development and
without that staying up to date it would
be in a way a stale kind of piece for
maybe film museum but it's always about
us because this is what movies should do
tell stories about us you know we have
to find ourselves in that story and we
have to experience or go through the all
the pains and the joys and worries the
hopes and suspense that the characters
on on the screen go through and that's
how we sort of draw a little frame about
our existences and and can look at our
lives it even though it sounds
far-fetched this is the very reason for
for storytelling so do you think there
will ever be a time if Daniel Craig ever
gives up the role that we will see a
different type of bond you know a black
bond a gay bond a female bonds do you
think the franchise should be brave and
do something really different I think
the the the franchise should be brave
it wouldn't be James Bond if it is
Jemima bond I think I think it would be
great to have a movie Jemima bond you
know or Jamie bond James Bond is James
Bond you know and and if it makes sense
it makes sense because as I said it's
it's about making sense of our own
little lives I don't know whether
whether it makes sense to have a female
James Bond and I you know it's not James
Bond